the mothers chose to protest yesterday
because it is 24 years as of yesterday
since Columbine now they've been
planning this protest for weeks never
expecting the shooting of Ralph yarl to
thrust this community into the National
Gun Violence debate
it may not be our kids but it's going to
be someone's kids and that hurts just as
much Sarah Ennis Anna Simpson Annie Noel
and Eileen noblock are Suburban Kansas
City moms who say if they don't speak up
they're part of the problem so many
women out here today this was their
first protest this was my first protest
they'd never done anything like this and
it felt scary and uncomfortable and we
want other moms like us to get
uncomfortable a little bit that's why
just three weeks ago after the Nashville
school shooting they created lives on
the line a group stretching across
District State and party lines demanding
an end to gun violence we don't have
enough white people who are willing to
stand up and say this is not right
because we know that black children and
LGBT people are affected by gun violence
at a much higher level a recent CBS News
poll showed 61 percent of parents say
their children are worried about gun
violence my eight-year-old woke up the
other night and she said Mom I had this
dream and there were guns you have
mental health issues everywhere but when
you pair those with absolute chaos in
terms of gun legislation this is what
you get and now we're dealing with
children who are being shot doing
day-to-day things and it's just
intolerable with gun gridlock in
Washington states are Paving their own
way in both directions this week
Washington state will become the 10th to
ban assault weapons and Florida's
governor recently signed a bill allowing
permitless concealed carry the 26th
state to do so and in Tennessee despite
the Nashville school shooting last month
Representatives just passed a law
protecting gun manufacturers against
lawsuits the states with the weakest gun
laws have gun death rates that are three
times higher than states with strong
restrictions and as gun sales have
spiked so have gun homicides I think
about it every day I drop my children
off at school every day every single
time
every day I say I love you and I pray
not exaggerating I'm not I pray it's not
the last time yeah
one mom told us perhaps there needs to
be a change in narrative maybe approach
ending gun violence as what could be the
greatest achievement of our era Nate
Adriana thank you